et on va jouer les et vous jouez avec
nous bien sûr on fait tout le tour de
l'actu et aux États-Unis pourquoi la
police a arrêté deux enfants
âgés de 10 et 11 ans ils ont volé 40 kg
de bonbons ils ont gagné une bagarre
contre Guillaume Genton ils ont hacké le
site du FBI où ils ont retrouvé au
théorie été retrouvés au volant d'une
voiture à 350 km/h 350 km de chez eux et
bonbon les bonbons 40 km
je pense la des oui c'est une bonne
voiture
c'est les chauffeurs de la semaine deux
enfants Américains disent 11 ans voler
la voiture de leur mère et son parti à
350 km de chez eux elle leur avait
confisqué leur console de jeux
contactez pour un vol de voiture des
policiers américains retrouvent le
véhicule dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi dernier et la reine mais à
l'intérieur il tombe sur un garçon de 10
ans et une fille de 11 ans qui venait de
fuguer pour une raison particulière nous
avons appris que les deux enfants
voulaient à leur mère parce qu'elle
avait confisqué leurs appareils
électroniques ensemble ils ont parcouru
pas moins de 350 km avant d'être stoppée
et d'être récupéré par leur mère
quelques-uns mais les deux enfants ne
risquent pas d'être inquiétés puisque
l'infraction de conduite sans permis ne
sera pas retenu contre ces mineurs
[Musique]
alors
qui a déjà volé la voiture de ses
parents dites la vérité
[Rires]
et j'avais dit à Sophie et Florence de
garder la place de parking parce qu'il
fallait la remettre au même au même
endroit quand tu le vois la voiture si
quelqu'un d'autre prend la plage c'était
j'étais fou j'avais 13 ans et je pars à
toute vitesse sur l'avenue et je double
la gendarmerie moi
je double la gendarmerie du coup on
serrer moumi les menottes et j'avais par
chance ma sœur elle rentrait chez moi et
elle avait son permis elle est 18 ans
elle m'a elle a ramené la voiture et
elle est partie me balancer à mon père
qui dormait à 3h du matin je suis pas à
peine de balancer lui dire à demain mais
je suis allé conduire bah 13 ans
je me rappelle mon père il avait acheté
genre une Audi mes frères une Audi des
années 10 une catastrophe Bordeaux avec
des sièges jaunes et il était persuadé
que c'était une voiture de taulier frère
il avait dû la payer 800 balles et il
nous a dit j'ai trouvé une affaire de
ouf l'Audi elle avait 400000 km
et il la mettait dans un garage qui
était à 100 mètres de la maison genre il
avait trouvé un garage mes frères un
garage frère c'était pas les portes
électriques c'est les portes qui
s'ouvraient comme ça ça veut dire que tu
devais les glisser comme ça ça veut dire
à 4h du matin tu rentres de boiter tu
dois ouvrir les portes comme ça bon et
il a jamais su je sais pas si nous si on
regarde aujourd'hui il va il va il va le
savoir
et bien
j'ai volé l'audit non ouais ouais j'ai
volé quel âge on est en train de dire
je m'étais j'avais pris les clés du
garage et tous les soirs en fait
j'escalade chez moi tous les soirs je
sortais pratiquement tous les soirs
voilà et j'escalade chez moi et je
prenais mais j'avais pas le permis et il
faut pas le faire du tout ça
et je prenais l'Audi de mon père
l'Audi Bordeaux avec des sièges orange
triple phare et les gars mais vous
alliez où avec est-ce que je vais
chercher je vais chercher trois meufs
avec l'audiez vous avez raconté donc je
pars des Lilas mon frère
avec un autre copain qui avait des
lunettes mon frère on dirait qu'il
allait faire de la plongée
Olivier gabizon qui est à côté de moi on
va chercher trois meufs à l'époque on va
chercher trois meubles je vous dis qui
habitait dans le 8e arrondissement pour
nous c'était magnifique le huitième
on va chercher les meufs on les connaît
pas c'est un copain qui nous a dit voilà
ouais elles sont sympas dis mon pavés au
restaurant on dit d'accord à l'époque on
s'appelait ouais bon d'accord j'ai dit
on va aller chercher les trois meufs
montent dans la voiture déjà elle voit
l'Audi
[Applaudissements]
là déjà de l'extérieur et elle monte
dedans et elle voit les sièges oranges
et là on voit qu'on passe complètement
au travail on va dans une pizzeria à
côté du huitième je vous l'avais dit je
voulais dire à raconter et je suis avec
mes copains et je dis à mes copains à un
moment parce qu'il y a un autre copain
qui nous rejoint et on prend des pizzas
on commande et tout et je leur dis les
gars je vous le dis on passe
complètement au travers
on y arrivera pas les gars c'est où ça
va nous coûter une tonne parce que je
t'explique nous on avait 10 balles à
trois donc voilà ou bien ou bien et pas
descendre la voiture est mal garée et on
se sauve mais non les pizzas arrivent
et là j'ai et là j'ai un de mes copains
qui parlent il va voir la voiture s'il
te plaît et revient il dit vas-y vas-y
vite je suis en train de mettre un truc
je pars et là on prend la voiture on
s'est sauvé on est retournés
[Applaudissements]
histoire est vrai sérieux histoire j'ai
remis la voiture dans le dans le garage
et mon père ne l'a jamais su euh il n'a
jamais su et je me rappelle j'avais un
truc à chaque fois que j'arrivais à
faire ce qu'on appelait une Windows
parce que je passais par la fenêtre tout
ça et je rentrais par la fenêtre ne le
faites pas c'était n'importe quoi et
donc j'arrivais comme ça je faisais
attention
gagner
et un jour mon père il entend du bruit
et il vient dans ma chambre maintenant
frère moi je suis habillé mon frère mes
frères j'étais sorti jusqu'à 4h du matin
demain j'ai cours à 8h je suis comme ça
dans le lit je mets la couette jusqu'ici
là il y a mon père qui rentre dans la
chambre tu as pas entendu du bruit vas-y
mais qu'est-ce que tu veux toi j'ai
contrôle demain là
[Rires]
j'étais habillé de la tête aux pieds mon
frère et ici ça sent la cigarette ici
bah je sais pas et bah il y a peut-être
quelqu'un qui a fait un feu je veux pas
te dire
en fait bah oui c'est de la meilleure
défense ouais bien sûr voilà donc il me
regarde et ma mère à mon avis je vais
avoir un message je vais faire défoncer
j'ai un deuxième question pourquoi ce
chien coûtait plus de 1000 euros à une
compagnie aérienne il a mangé des
valises de certains passagers il a mordu
un pilote qui n'a pas pu travailler
pendant 15 jours non mais ça saute il
avait la laine de Raymond au réveil
il a fait que péter pendant exactement
c'est un bouledogue
alors je sais pas c'est un français ou
en anglais
un couple a passé un moment assez
compliqué pendant un vol reliant Paris à
Singapour et se retrouver face à un
chien qui pétait et ronflé pendant 13
heures je vous jure du coup la compagnie
a décidé de les dédommager regardez
[Musique]
vous avez sans doute déjà passé un vol
désagréable mais ce n'est sans doute
rien comparé à ce qu'on vécu de
néo-zélandais
le couple embarque pour un vol de trésor
reliant Paris à Singapour mais problème
les deux amoureux réalistes très vite
qui vont passer le voyage à côté d'un
chien d'assistance qui bave qui ronfle
et qui pète j'ai dit à mon mari tu dois
régler ça nous ne pouvons pas avoir un
chien assis à côté de nous pendant aussi
longtemps agacé le couple qui n'avait
pas été prévenu alors accepter d'être
déclassé pour ne pas rester à côté du
bulldogue mais alors que la compagnie
aérienne c'est dans un premier temps
excusé en leur offrant des chèques
cadeaux de 73 dollars puis deux bons de
voyage de 118 dollars les deux
néo-zélandais ont finalement été
dédommagés à hauteur de 1300 euros
alors
sachez qu'il émettait de nombreuses
flatulences et il bavés pourtant ce
n'était pas un ex de Daniel
non mais c'est vrai voilà et c'est vrai
que cette histoire est folle est-ce que
vous êtes déjà arrivé de plus en plus
les compagnies aériennes vont être
confrontés à ça parce que c'est ce que
l'on appelle des chiens ou des chats
supports émotionnels d'accord et la
législation elle est un peu floue elle
t'autorise à attacher ce chien ou ce
chat à une structure c'est pas forcément
la structure de ton siège ça peut être
celle la structure du siège à côté et
une hôtesse m'a raconté un jour qu'elle
s'est retrouvée en business avec le
passager et à côté un chien qui était
grand comme ça et il pouvait rien faire
[Rires]
vision incroyable parce qu'elle était
derrière dans le galet elle voyait la
tête du passager et le chien qui était
fou et encore là on est en train de
légiférer aux États-Unis parce que là
c'est chien et chat mais les animaux
émotionnels ça peut être un caïman ça
peut être une poule ça peut être un
serpent ça peut être oui
merci en tout cas de l'info tous les
deux merci écoutez cette audio
de quoi parle cette personne oh la vache
400000 du nombre de conquêtes de
Jean-Michel maire
[Rires]
du nombre de rats au mètre carré à Paris
ou du nombre de contre chroniqueurs qui
ont fait la photo de classe de rentrée
TPMP
deux couples ont découvert lors d'une
balade en forêt 400000 euros dans un sac
poubelle grâce à leur chien et oui c'est
spécial ce soir ils ont voulu être
honnête et ont rapporté le but
[Musique]
une enquête a été ouverte et finalement
ils pourront en récupérer que la moitié
pourquoi parce que quand vous trouvez
quelque chose sur un terrain il y a la
moitié pour vous et la moitié pour le
propriétaire et c'est la commune qui
était propriétaire du terrain dans le
Var donc la commune à la moitié ils
doivent être dégoûtés il y avait une
quatre classes de 500 billets de 200
euros il voulait tout mais ils ont la
moitié
j'ai perdu 10 € dans la Logan enfin tu
me les a carottes non mais
tu sais pourquoi parce que j'aurais eu
peur en fait parce que je me dis 400000
€ en petite coupure dans la forêt c'est
louche je me dis ça sous ça appartient à
des mafieux ou un truc comme ça
tu me retrouves après une saucisse ou tu
vas pour préserver cet argent même si
c'est de l'argent sale ça la vraie
question
tu perds tout l'argent oui mais l'argent
oui mais espèce d'abruti là non
il faut que tu es bête
imagine imagine les 400000 ils sont à
des mafieux et ils savent que c'est toi
qui vient de me chercher j'étais en
train de vous les garder on avait voulu
prendre
j'ai vu un gars
là il y a pas d'enquête qui a été faite
moi je pense que je les rendrai bah oui
si ça personne tu vois ce que je fais
moi vas-y c'est quoi ça sera à moi tu
prends les 400000 €, tu les offres à
plein de gens exactement
[Applaudissements]
vous volez pas au chocolat vous piquez
la voiture vos parents vous partez la
pizza
[Applaudissements]